يتجول سليمان حسب الكريم بسلاحه داخل سوق
الضعين غربيه السودان في مشهد اصبح مالوفا
في مدن اقليم دارفور فمنذ اندلاع القتال
بين الجيش والدعم سريع في منتصف ابريل
الماضي عدد سلاح مره اخرى الى الظهور
بكثره في ايدي المواطنين بالاحياء
والاسواق حجتهم في ذلك حمايه انفسهم من
النهب والسلب والله لحمايه نفسي بس وانا
زلت تاجر وقاعد في الخلا وشايل السلاح من
النهب لعدم حفظ الامن لانه ما في اسي دوله
بتحمانا
من النهب والسلب عشان كذا انا شايل السلاح
لحمايه نفسي وعشر دارفور في السنوات
السابقه صراعات عديده متواصله استخدم فيها
السلاح بشكل سافر مما جعل بعض القيادات
الاهليه تتخوف من تكرار ذات الخلافات
القديمه التي عاشها الاقليم بسبب السلاح
والسيوله الامنيه
لذلك نحن نقول هذه الخطوه خطوه غير موفقه
ونحن نطالب المجتمع الدولي والاخوه
الوسطاء السعوديين والمتحده ان يقفوا على
هذه الحاله لان هذه الازمه ستصبح ازمه
يمكنكم تضييق على السودانيين فيما ينادي
بعض المواطنين بالمضي قدما في عمليات جمع
السلاح بدلا من تقنين انتشاره خوفا من
الانزلاق الى الحرب الاهليه بدرفور مشيرين
الى ان بعض المناطق ما زالت ساخنه نحن
نرفض جمله وتفصيله لان السلاح عند المواطن
ذات نجمعه نحن الان نحن مع جهه وتجمع
السلاح جمع السلاح ومحاربه الظواهر السلبه
نحن الان ما داريين سرقات كل الحاجات
محاربينها تماما وما دايرين اي خلل
وتقولوا جهات مختصه انه رغم الحملات
المتكرره فلا يزال السلاح بكافه انواعه
بحوزه سكان دارفور انقسام للمجتمع
بيدارفور بين مؤيدين ورافض التسليح بغرض
الحمايه وبين مجموعه الرفض وتاييد قاسم
مشترك وحمايه الارواح والممتلكات وتعزيز
الامن والسلام
صالح ابو علامه لقناته العربيه والحدث
اقليم دارفور غربيه السودان لمتابعه
المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج والقصص
الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات